good evening 47
your destination is the paris fashion
show by san guin
one of europe's leading couture brands
your targets are sanguine owner viktor
novikov
a former oligarch turned fashion mogul
and his partner dahlia margolis
a retired supermodel an iconic power
couple on the global fashion scene
and two of the most dangerous people in
the world
novikov and margolis are in fact the
ringleaders of iago
an enigmatic spiring that deals in the
global elite's most valuable secrets
unscrupulous and opportunistic iago has
caused disastrous security leaks all
over the globe
when crimean separatists caused a deadly
meltdown at the odessa nuclear power
plant
iago gave them access to the plant
security network
and when the delgado drug cartel shot
down the plane of president hernandez
and his family
iago provided the classified flight
plans
now navikov and mogolas have obtained a
knock list of british undercover agents
which they plan to sell at a secret iago
auction during the sandwin show
so our client mi6 need us to stop the
ringleaders before the knock list ends
up in the wrong hands
the sand grin show will be swarming with
security and viktor novikov will be the
focus of everyone's attention
but despite his posturing he is merely
the money man
the real target is dalia margolis
beautiful
and brilliant she is a master
manipulator and the true brains behind
iago
two targets a highly public event
at first glance an impossible task
then again i do know how you love a
challenge
i will leave you to prepare
c
welcome to paris 47 the show is just
about to start
this is the red carpet event of the
season and the guest list is a veritable
who's who with the global fashion elite
you will find victor novotrov basking in
the spotlight
dalia margolis hosts the heavily guarded
auction on the second floor
for a group of iago's top customers
now event security will keep a watchful
eye on any suspicious activity
but i trust your timeless look shall fit
right
47
newly appointed head designer sebastian
sato at the helm
tonight
love the look sir
i i don't know they're so thin looking
oh
show stoppers
haley's been caught
not for me
oh
oh perfect this is exactly what i wanted
to happen
ah
hi yes
it's downtown yes the sanguine fashion
show
i'm about to leave you with it to not
comment them
my internet messages drop the equipment
according to the young fashion blogger
novikov has agreed to do a live
interview
this could be a good time to catch the
sengency
yo off guard location however is
currently unknown
and in any case block needs a
replacement lens for the camera
may i suggest you help a girl in need
it's a web scene all the rage
you know about fashion lifestyle
oh come on
oh
anymore
watch it amigo
[Laughter]
ugh
well
huh
hey better safe than sorry right
yeah hi excuse me man i couldn't help it
over here
is this what you're looking for
oh god yes yes thank you so much
just glad i could help thanks mr you're
a lifesaver
but the pros do their job okay
i know i know your security you're cool
and all but i can't let you through
sorry
there is never no
okay
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
so
say what welcome
security's tight here we're not letting
you guys through sorry man
oh
[Music]
blair
look i don't care if it's the holy grail
just would you just
back up a little bit you're making me
darker um
hey what's your problem sir
anything
whoa just checking a sound
hang on
scratch that we're good
hey we got a situation here release that
person right now
what's going on
come on we got a casualty proceeding
with
damn
man got some strange noises here looking
into it over
freaks
oh let me do it i love fixing fuse boxes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that is dalia margolis supermodel turned
spy master
now ladies and gentlemen
thank you you are too
really too kind
i have been told that these are my most
accessible designs yet
but don't let the bright colors and the
classical cuts fool you
no no no no the themes i'm exploring
here are perhaps my darkest yet
i've explored feelings of powerlessness
the rest would you throw yourself on a
grenade to save me
love the outfit you accept my own
as it happens i have the perfect
now pay attention i want you to go to
new york seek out jessica
and do what you do best
the girl is bright young beautiful you
should be right at your alley
thank you what did she do good
befriend him get his trust i'm
consulting are planning a merger
i want to know with whom and at what
price
that's it for now
that's for you keep it on you at all
times
last a last resort
you must be joking that's that's what i
think it is our marks are not nice
oh no this is not happening
hey stop
watch your six
oh
now that's for you keep it on you at all
[Music]
times
god
[Music]
oh god oh god yeah
that's for you keep it on you at all
[Music]
[Music]
times
the show is just
for now that's for you
keep it on you at all times
[Music]
good
[Music]
so
[Music]
got reason to believe it's not an
accident
[Music]
command do you copy all units my
goldness is down
our goalless is down
[Music]
all right stand down you still have a
threat don't get too calm
so
yeah i've been expecting my call
indeed i have been following your band's
career with
great interest and wished
enlighten me nicholas hey what's up
very good is it classified
so
that is viktor novikov head of sanguine
and ring leader of iago quite the resume
the man of the hour
yes
sorry sir
[Music]
so
what
[Music]
holy freaking christmas
[Music]
go hey
uh
i like your face
come on think we got some trouble
cover the aryan grids check your corners
go
good
so
[Music]
yes
uh
clearly need it
so
what the hell is he doing up there
all right be sure to check and frisk
anyone who has not been invited who
works up here okay
what are you doing up there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
please
no uh look i've got another accident
so
this is
[Music]
just like that yeah oh i couldn't be
happier with the way this has gone
bravo oh smut display
specialist suckers are gonna pay for
this
oh there goes lotus explosion
[Applause]
what
hello found someone unconscious
i think better get someone down here
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
goodbye
over there
ours is not the question why ours is to
do and die
hold your fire he disappeared
[Music]
so
how was moscow kamarov is gone
i set him up as a language spy it's
quite the scandal at the fsb
his death will not be investigated
your turn very well
the secrets of the global elite
five years of work everything we've
collected
this thing makes wikileaks look like a
gossip rag
the pen beats the sword huh
i have found that whoever wields the
sword decides who holds the pen
smile victor your reputation is safe
now run along i'm sure you have pretty
dresses to attend to
victor good luck with the show
i have a feeling it's going to be the
one you will be remembered for
you